الياس هل من مقاربه جديده تبحث فيما يتعلق
بملف المحتجزين في قطاع
غزه يبدو كذلك والمؤشر على ذلك هو ان مجلس
الحرب يلتئم وبعد ذلك يلتئم ايضا المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
في اسرائيل وهو المخول في حسم واتخاذ
القرارات المصيريه في اسرائيل ومن الواضح
ان التئام المجلسين الواحد طلو الاخر هو
مؤشر على ان شيئا جديا ما يبحث يطرح يناقش
ربما ايضا يجري التصويت عليه هذه الليله
او على الاقل مناقشته كنقاط اولي رغم او
بعد ذلك بعد ايام ربما يطرح مره اخرى
للتصويت عليه لكن واضح بان اهميه الاجتماع
تاتي ايضا في اطار الانباء التي تتحدث عن
اجتماع مرتقب للوسطاء بحضور رئيس المساد
الاسرائيلي ورئيس الشباك وكذلك رئيس سي اي
اي الامريكي وهذا يعني بان هنالك مقترح
جدي يبدو انه مطروح او يناقش وايضا مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي يناقشه ويحوله مره اخرى
للنقاش في المجلس الامني المصغر اهميه
الاجتماع انها انه ياتي ايضا كما يبدو
لمناقشه المقترح الاسرائيلي الذي قدم
للوسطاء في الايام الماضيه والذي قيل بان
المقاومه ردت عليه بالرفض ووضعت شروطا
عليه فيما يتعلق ب
ضروره انهاء الحرب وانسحاب اسرائيل من
قطاع غزه في اطار اي صفقه للتبادل الاسرى
وهذا موقف عبرت عنه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في اكثر من مناسبه ورفضته اسرائيل ايضا من
جانبها جمله وتفصيلا واليوم هذه الليله
تحدث في هذا الشان ايضا رئيس حركه شاس لي
المتدينين الشرقيين اليدري وهو شريك اساسي
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه ويجلس وايضا بصفه
مراقب في مجلس الحرب وقال بانه وجه وزراء
حركته بان يصوتوا ضد ايه صفقه لتبادل
الاسرى تشمل وقف الحرب وانسحاب اسرائيل من
قطاع غزه وبقاء حماس على راس السلطه في
قطاع غزه وهذا موقف كما يبدو يحظى باجماع
كبير في مجلس الحرب في اي المجلس الوزاري
المصغر وكذلك في الهيئه العامه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه اذا ما الجديد الذي يبحث اي
حقيقه لا نعرف لكن من الواضح بان اسرائيل
تحاول ان توازن من ناحيه بين الشروط
والخطوط الحمراء التي تضعها المقاومه وبين
الضغط الشعبي المتزايد حتى في الدقائق
الاخيره حيث يتواصل الحراك الشعبي في
اسرائيل الذي يضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من جانب العائلات لاتمام صفقه
الشرطه الاسرائيليه هذه الليله اعتقلت
شخصين حاول اغلاق احد المحاور الرئيسيه
هنا في مدينه تلي ابيب بمعنى ان الحراك
الشعبي متواصل ومن الواضح بان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ت حاول كما قلت ان توازن بين
شروط المقاومه من جهه الضغط الشعبي من جهه
اخرى وبالتالي الذهاب نحو
صفقه على مراحل لتبادل الاسرى دون
اعلان تتام لوقف اطلاق النار لكن ربما وقف
لاطلاق النار لشهر او شهرين